and he's got a beautiful golf swing  loves up his right side I mean for think  about what he does for a living and then  he's able to do this and make it look  this good this effortless is pretty see  why he's gotten a few invites to play in  our our events got a great motion all  right Steph if I would say one piece of  devices they stick a load your right leg  a little bit more put a little more  weight into it as you go back I know I  you can see the hip weight goes into the  hip but just load it a little bit more  other than that he clearly hips well  it's unbelievable golf swing and looking  forward to playing with you make us some  cash off you too